queridos amigos amigas No es habitual
decirlo pero si la Unión Europea siempre
ha intentado presentarse a sí mismo como
poco menos que la Dalí de la limpieza y
la transparencia Lo cierto es que el
último año no ha sido precisamente Bueno
a tenor de todas las noticias que han
ido apareciendo sobre casos de
corrupción en el parlamento europeo
puede que muchos tengáis la sensación de
que el corazón político del proyecto
europeo está infiltrado por agentes
extranjeros hasta el cuello Ah que
creéis que exagero pues fijaos
correspondencia filtrada arroja luz
sobre los vínculos entre eurodiputada
letona y el fsb un caso de soborno Abre
grietas en el parlamento europeo y
encuentra dinero oculto los fiscales
dicen que el glamuroso estilo de vida de
una parlamentaria europea escondía un
escándalo de corrupción Catarina
escándalo de corrupción de Qatar
Marruecos también implicado en un
presunto pago a panzeri Rusia Qatar
Marruecos incluso mauritania lo que
hasta ahora se hacía ver como un espacio
puro transparente y limpio acumula los
últimos meses más escándalos que las
infidelidades de Tiger boots todo empezó
amigos a finales del 2022 cuando se
destapó un macr caso de corrupción por
el que varios europarlamentarios
recibieron sobornos de Qatar y de otros
países como Marruecos y mauritania
queridos amigos amigas lo que os vamos a
contar en este vídeo son Ni más ni menos
que algunas de las mayores vergüenzas de
la política europea Aunque Quizás lo más
sorprendente es el papel que un país
como Marruecos ha jugado en toda esta
historia preparados pues gasolina y
arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bien para ponernos en situación vamos a
empezar contando Qué es exactamente el
Qatar Gate o el moroco Gate la excisión
marroquí de este mismo escándalo
hablamos del mayor caso de corrupción de
la historia de la Unión Europea un caso
que antes de explotar en diciembre del
2022 estuvo bastante tiempo bajo
investigación con pinchazos telefónicos
incluidos Al final todo sal ó por los
aires cuando la policía belga descubrió
al padre de baky una eurodiputada
socialdemócrata griega y vicepresidenta
del europarlamento saliendo de un hotel
con una maleta en esa maleta no llevaba
cromos sino la friolera de agarrados a
la Silla
750,000 en efectivo casi 1 millón de
dólares al mismo tiempo la policía
también detuvo a Antonio pateri un ex
eurodiputado socialdemócrata italiano
que después pues se ha sabido que es Ni
más ni menos que El capo de toda esta
trama pero no solo eso entre un viernes
y un lunes las autoridades belgas
encontraron un millón y medio de euros
en efectivo en varias casas y oficinas
de los investigados vamos que se había
montado un negocio por todo lo grande
además paneri también canalizaba dinero
de Qatar y de Marruecos a través de una
ong con sede en Bruselas una ong que él
mismo había fundado en 2019 una ong que
supuestamente pues luchaba contra las
violaciones de los derechos humanos con
dinero Eso sí de Qatar y de Marruecos
curioso no os parece pero es que aún hay
más esa ong la llevaba junto a su
asistente Francesco georgi que es el
novio de Eva ky vamos que al final todo
que quedaba en la familia el caso amigos
es que el objetivo de todo este
entramado corrupto era que esos
eurodiputados constituyeran lobis para
influir en el parlamento europeo sobre
ciertos temas sensibles siguiendo
siempre Claro está los intereses de
Qatar Marruecos y hasta
mauritania Hablamos de una trama sin
precedentes en la historia de la Unión
Europea una red de engaños sobornos
maletines llenos de dinero en efectivo y
lobis ilegales impulsados por
eurodiputados en ejercicio y también
antiguos miembros de la cámara una red
corrupta cuyos miembros se compraban
inmuebles en Cash manipulaban dosieres
sobre violaciones de Derechos Humanos en
ciertos países vetabel reconocimiento de
activistas contra la esclavitud u
ocultaban acciones de servicios de
espionaje
extranjeros vale puede que muchos de
vosotros ya hayáis oído hablar de todo
esto del catar Gate pero casi seguro que
la última vez que lo hicisteis fue hace
ya bastante tiempo y además sin mucho
detalle me equivoco es posible que
incluso creáis que el tema ya está
completamente cerrado y solucionado sin
embargo no nada más lejos de la
[Música]
realidad las investigaciones continúan a
día de hoy y poco a poco se siguen
publicando detalles los últimos hace
apenas dos meses cuando se filtraron
cientos de documentos del caso cuyo
alcance es mucho mayor del que se
pensaba De hecho aquí es donde digamos
que empiezan ya a aparecer cosas un
tanto raras Y es que ahora poco más de
un año después de que explotara todo
este escándalo no hay ni un solo acusado
en la cárcel y lo que es aún peor el
fiscal Federal a cargo del caso Rafael
malagnini dimitió de su cargo En octubre
del 2023 boom de repente encontró un
trabajo mejor y algo parecido ocurrió
también con Michael Clay el primer juez
belga que se encargó de este asunto tuvo
que dimitir tras descubrirse que su hijo
su propio hijo tenía una empresa con el
hijo de otra eurodiputada también
involucrada en este meac caso de
corrupción y aún más en el marco de las
investigaciones había solicitudes de
arresto y de interrogatorio para un
ministro catarí y un diplomático
marroquí que de la noche a la mañana
desaparecieron algunas como
bastante sorprendentes el juez belga que
hasta hace poco dirigía la investigación
de corrupción Qatar Gate retiró una
orden de arresto internacional contra un
alto funcionario qatarí a cambio de la
ayuda de doja para lograr la liberación
de un trabajador humanitario belga
detenido por Irán qué Qué te parece
hacemos truque impunidad a cambio de
mediación no parece un mal negocio No sé
hasta Pedro Sánchez estaría orgulloso
pero es que aquí no acaba toda la
historia también hay políticos que a
pesar de las fuertes pruebas sobre su
implicación ni siquiera han sido
investigados por ejemplo la eurodiputada
socialdemócrata belga María arena
reconoció haber aceptado viajes y
haberse hospedado en Qatar y en
Marruecos a todo trapo y a gastos
pagados por estos países y no solo eso
en casa de su hijo encontraron casi
300,000 eur en efectivo y origen
desconocido pero sin embargo está libre
y sin cargos para má hri panzeri y arena
dirigieron la subcomisión de Derechos
Humanos manos del parlamento europeo Sí
sí de derechos humanos y tanto Kylie
como arena siguen siendo a día de hoy
eurodiputados
y claro con todo esto puede que muchos
pues os estéis preguntando Pero cómo
demonios es posible que todo esto haya
pasado en el corazón mismo de la Unión
Europea y que además haya ocurrido sin
pena ni Gloria pues queridos amigos así
están las cosas Y es que a ver los
eurodiputados cobran salarios de más de
10,000 mensuales precisamente para
evitar que se corrompan esa al menos es
la justificación que se da y aunque la
avaricia en algunos es algo Inevitable
la tibia respuesta del europarlamento
pues qué queréis que os diga da que
pensar y si en la Unión Europea hay más
infiltraciones y presiones extranjeras
de las que pensábamos cómo puede ser que
un país tan pobre y irrelevante en la
escena internacional como es Marruecos
pueda crear una enorme trama de
corrupción en Bruselas para controlar la
política comunitaria Pues bien en este
vídeo os vamos a hablar sobre todo de
este segundo caso el de Marruecos qué
buscaba exactamente rabate en el
parlamento europeo y la pregunta más
importante qué le debe la Unión Europea
a Marruecos Pues bien veámoslo
moroco Gate la mano de
rabat el escándalo Qatar Gate tiene como
os hemos dicho una ramificación marroquí
esta ramificación a la que se le llama
moroco Gate no ocupado tantas portadas
en los medios de comunicación europeos
pero es todavía más sorprendente que la
injerencia de Qatar en la política
europea pero ahora bien cómo se infiltró
Marruecos en los pasillos de Bruselas
Pues veréis esta historia tiene dos
rostros principales por un lado está el
exe eurodiputado Antonio panceri y el
que todavía es embajador de Marruecos en
Polonia abderrahim ammun que servía como
contacto de rabat con los políticos
corruptos
europeos Aunque tanto Qatar como
Marruecos niegan tajantemente su
participación en ninguna trama para
corromper la política europea Lo cierto
es que los investigadores belgas tienen
pruebas de sobra para refutar esa
defensa en concreto Bélgica cree que
atmung jugó un papel clave a la hora de
canalizar el dinero con el que se pagaba
a los eurodiputados corruptos incluso la
mujer y la hija de panzeri se
beneficiaban de los fondos marroquíes a
través de una tarjeta de
crédito El caso es que admon y panzeri
copr presidían la comisión parlamentaria
mixta Unión Europea Marruecos que es Por
así decirlo el principal enlace de
contacto entre el parlamento europeo y
Marruecos Pues bien básicamente bajo la
dirección de estos dos personajes esa
comisión trabajó no para defender los
intereses de Europa respecto a Marruecos
sino al revés de hecho en unos
documentos marroquíes filtrados por un
hacker entre los años 2014 y 2015 rabat
calificaba paneri de Gran Aliado e
íntimo amigo llegando a decir que era
capaz de contrarrestar El creciente
activismo de sus oponentes en el
europarlamento ahora bien exactamente
qué necesitaba Marruecos de la Unión
Europea qué podían ofrecer estos
eurodiputados corruptos a rabat Pues
bien os lo contamos ahora mismo
[Música]
atentos corrupción presión
chantajes la relación entre Marruecos y
la Unión Europea Especialmente con los
países del sur como España Italia o
Portugal se podría definir como una
asociación de mutuo interés por un lado
la Unión Europea necesita Marruecos para
contener uno de los mayores problemas
que lleva años enfrentando Europa la
inmigración ilegal un problema que ha
puesto en hacke varias veces a los
gobiernos de España Italia y de Grecia y
que en el caso especialmente de España
Marruecos utiliza frecuentemente como
chantaje por ejemplo con cosas como esta
España y Marruecos en crisis diplomática
después de que 8000 inmigrantes entrar
en el territorio español en aquella
ocasión Incluso se vio como las fuerzas
de seguridad marroquíes no hacían
absolutamente nada para evitar que miles
de personas as saltase en la frontera
con España en ceuta y este amigos es tan
solo un ejemplo del poder que tiene
Marruecos para desestabilizar y llegado
el caso chantajear a los países europeos
pero la inmigración no es la única vía
que utilizan en concreto en el caso
moroco Gate y según Las investigaciones
belgas se mencionan en documentos
expresamente la cuestión de los derechos
de la pesca y del Sáhara occidental
ahora bien Qué es exactamente eso de los
derechos de pesca pues veréis la Unión
Europea tiene la competencia exclusiva
en el ámbito de la política comercial
común y en eso se incluyen también la
firma de acuerdos pesqueros para que los
buques europeos puedan faenar en
caladeros extranjeros algo así como
alquilar las aguas de pesca de otros
países y claro la cuestión es que un
trato favorable con Marruecos en torno a
los derechos de pesca conllevaba ciertas
contrapartidas concretamente según los
servicios secretos belgas los
eurodiputados implicados acordaron pues
desviar las críticas a Marruecos en
materia de derechos humanos y sobre el
estatus del Sáhara occidental que
Marruecos se ha empeñado en cambiar de
una vez para
siempre
en 2016 el rey marroquí Mohamed vi
declaró que el asunto del Sáhara
occidental sería a partir de entonces la
mayor prioridad del reino lai en materia
de política exterior ese discurso vino
acompañado de un cambio radical en la
forma de hacer diplomacia por parte de
rabat según el periodista marroquí
abubakar yamay ahora exiliado los
diplomáticos marroquíes desde entonces
actúan con una arrogancia y unas formas
sin precedentes y se empezaron a
permitir cosas que antes estaban
prohibidas muy probablemente se refería
precisamente a cosas como la corrupción
por parte de figuras como admon a
miembros del parlamento
europeo Y si bien el moroco Gate no
representaba una cantidad mayoritaria de
dinero dentro del Qatar Gate Marruecos
sí que era el país más agresivo en sus
formas en 2019 por ejemplo admur negoció
un acuerdo financiero entre pateri y el
servicio de espionaje marroquí que es
conocido como la dirección general de
estudios y documentación pateri confesó
que él y su asistente georgi acordaron
recibir un mínimo de 50.000 euros
anuales cada uno a cambio Pues de ganar
voluntades a favor de los intereses de
Marruecos dentro y fuera del
europarlamento pero es que es más sus
contactos eran relativamente habituales
por ejemplo entre los años 2019 y 2022
admon panseri y el jefe de la
inteligencia marroquí Mohamed yasim
mansuri se vieron cara a cara varias
veces en rabat admon al ser una persona
extrovertida quería conocer al mayor
número de personas posible y por
supuesto a aquellos que podrían ser
útiles para la causa marroquí Pero ahí
ahí No termina todo panzeri también
ayudó a admon a ganarse las simpatía de
otros miembros del parlamento europeo
con responsabilidades sobre expedientes
en los que rabat estaba interesado por
ejemplo el diputado italiano
socialdemócrata Andrea cotolino se metió
de lleno en el moroco Gate por formar
parte del comité que investigaba el uso
por parte precisamente de Marruecos del
Software espí pegasus ahora bien puede
que os estéis preguntando exactamente
qué cosas concretas logró Marruecos al
influir dentro de la política europea
[Música]
No pues aparte de lo que ya os hemos
contado rabat consiguió votos en contra
de conceder el premio saharov de
Derechos Humanos parlamento europeo a
dos activistas que eran opositores a
Marruecos y mauritania también lograron
aprobar una resolución contra Argelia y
garantizar que las menciones a Marruecos
desaparecieran de un informe del
europarlamento sobre violaciones de
Derechos
Humanos sorprendidos Marruecos jugaba
sus anchas en los pasillos de Bruselas
ahora bien llegados hasta aquí pues
puede que muchos os estéis haciendo una
pregunta bastante lógica Qué dantes hizo
el parlamento europeo después de
descubrir
todo este pastel Pues bien la versión
oficial es que están colaborando
estrechamente con las autoridades belgas
en la investigación pero la realidad
queridos amigos es que los movimientos
del europarlamento desde que saltó este
caso en diciembre del 22 han estado más
encaminados a tapar agujeros y restaurar
su imagen que realmente a descubrir
hasta dónde llega la trama porque
investigaciones internas serias lo que
se dice serias digamos que ha habido
entre pocas O mejor dicho ninguna Eso sí
en enero del 2023 poco más de un mes
después del arresto de panseri y el
resto de sospechosos el parlamento
europeo aprobó por primera vez 25 años
una condena al historial de violación de
derechos humanos de Marruecos casualidad
me da que no obviamente esto enfadó
mucho a Marruecos y la respuesta pues no
tardó en llegar el fin del acuerdo
pesquero alienta los contactos entre
Marruecos y la Unión Europea pero el
polisario alerta es mantener la
piratería este lunes ha expirado el
protocolo de pesca Unión Europea
Marruecos a la espera del
pronunciamiento de la justicia europea
sobre un acuerdo declarado ilegal por la
explotación de los recursos marinos del
Sáhara occidental sin consentimiento del
polisario amigos esta disputa
diplomática está haciendo que la
estabilidad en algunos asuntos esté
pendiente de un
hilo Y es que aparte del acuerdo
pesquero rabat es también un
importantísimo socio para Europa en lo
que se refiere a la lucha contra el
terrorismo islamista aquí los
intercambios de inteligencia resultan
claves y tampoco se puede olvidar que
más de 2 millones de marroquíes viven en
Europa y entre 2s y 3 millones más de
descendientes de marroquíes que
lógicamente pues se sienten todavía muy
identificados con ese país de hecho se
sabe que hoy por hoy la inteligencia de
rabat pues está activamente
infiltrándose en las comunidades
marroquíes de varios países europeos que
para qué pues lógicamente para tratar de
influenciar a los jóvenes cultural y
políticamente aparte por supuesto de
controlar a los disidentes evidentemente
Las garras de Marruecos en Europa son
grandes y el moroco Gate es Quizás El
último y mayor escándalo de muchos otros
casos de injerencias marroquíes en la
política europea a distinta escala por
ejemplo en España conocemos casos más
que de sobras casos como estos más de
200 números de móvil españoles posibles
objetivos del programa Pía pegasus la
filtración de datos Revela la magnitud
de la vigilancia potencial de un cliente
de nso Group que se cree que es
Marruecos la eurocámara exige a España
Investigar espionaje de Marruecos al
gobierno Incluyendo a Sánchez El Español
Sánchez en un viaje secreto de
vacaciones a Marruecos que enfada la
oposición por el conflicto del Sahara ha
habido un cambio de última hora en el
destino de vacaciones de Pedro Sánchez
que nadie conocía Y a todo esto le
tenemos que sumar que frecuentemente
criminales de todo tipo criminales de
guante blanco narcos sicario e incluso
terroristas se refugian en Marruecos
precisamente para intentar escapar de
las autoridades europeas y claro la
cuestión la duda que ahora muchos
podemos tener Es que hará Bruselas con
todo esto qué ocurrirá con las
relaciones entre Marruecos y Europa
ahora que esta red de corrupción en el
europarlamento se ha desplomado
Aparentemente Pues bien aquí en Misal
politic estaremos muy atentos pero ahora
por el momento la pregunta es para todos
vosotros qué pensáis que debería hacer
la Unión Europea para evitar que se
vuelvan a repetir escándalos como este
debería la Unión Europea ser más dura
con Marruecos haciendo valer su posición
de superioridad económica política y
militar tiene solución el chantaje
constante que rodea todas las relaciones
entre los gobiernos europeos y el
gobierno marroquí como siempre déjanos
tus impresiones por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y ahora si este vídeo te ha
resultado interesante No olvides dar al
botón de like y suscribirte aiso al
politic Para no perderte ninguna novedad
bueno Y no olvides echarle un vistazo a
nuestra nueva apuesta el informe K una
vez más queridos amigos amigas Muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la
[Música]
próxima